Canada!
USA, oh, hey there.
It's been a while.
How are your provinces?
Oh, they grew up so fast.
You know, I got my hands full with 10,...
...I don't know how you take care of 50 states.
Yeah, you know, well, it's not easy,...
...the southern ones went through a rebellious phase.
And what about the adopted ones?
Oh, Alaska and Hawaii?
Yeah, I haven't told them yet,...
...but I think they've figured it out by now.
And the really loud one?
Texas is still Texas.
Oh, Canada.
We should, you know, hang out sometime, maybe play some baseball.
What?
What's baseball?
Oh, sorry, I gotta get this.
China, baby, how's it going?
Yes, I know I owe you a lot of money.
Always making it about money.
You know what, listen.
I will get it to you tomorrow.
Do you have like 4 trillion dollars I could borrow?
What am I saying, you're Canada.